let's start with kelly clarkson yeah and
kelly's latest victory in her divorce
from ex brandon blackstock
we officially bought our ranch vintage
valley over a year and a half ago
divorce is a really
thing
was it judge fair brandon
with the house in montana the ranch
kelly's ex spotted at lax yesterday may
just be in denial or may just need to
call his attorney the judge hasn't ruled
on it yet
according to a court filing obtained by
e.t a judge has ruled that the 10
million montana ranch blackstock is
currently living on is well officially
hers this is what we would call home
the filing also reveals that brandon who
was also kelly's manager has made a very
deliberate choice to transition from the
music and entertainment industry to
becoming a rancher full-time his
attorney also says brandon spends
minimal time regarding his
representation of his remaining client
blake shelton are you going to fight
that decision brandon
are you hoping to keep the ranch
kelly meanwhile may be sending brandon a
message with her music she recently
dropped this video for her new holiday
[Music]
single if you've been in like a
relationship that didn't work out that
doesn't mean it's like all rude
and you gotta wonder was kelly
referencing brandon at the ranch when
she switched up the lyrics to this billy
eilish song changing you made me
[Music]
despite her ranch win kelly's still
required to pay brandon almost two
hundred thousand dollars a month in
spousal and child support